بعد ساعات تنتهي هذه هي الحمله الانتخابيه
التي انطلقت منذ يوم 25 نوفمبر الفارس
وبحسب العديد من المراقبين وايضا حتى
الجمعيات المهتمه بالشان الانتفاضه فان
اعتبرت ان هذه الحمله كانت باهته وايضا
بطيئه وضعيفه ولم تشهد ايضا فعاليات
تنافسيه كبرى الاسباب حول ضعف هذه الحمله
الانتخابيه في الحقيقه هي تختلف من طرفا
الى اخر الاحزان السياسيه او اغلب الاحزاب
السياسيه التي قاطعه الانتخابات هذه
الانتخابات تقول ان من بين الاسباب
الرئيسيه هو اول المقاطعها للعمليه
الانتخابيه الثانيه تقول ان اولويات
التونسيين خلال هذه المرحله هي لا تتعلق
بالانتخابات او بالعمل الاساسي بقدر ما
تتعلق بالتداعيات الاقتصاديه والاجتماعيه
لهذه الازمه التي تعيش البلاد على تدهور
المحضر الشرائيه وايضا نظره المواد
الاساسيه فيما اعتبر اخره وخاصه من بين
الاحزاب التي تشارك في هذه الحمله في هذه
الانتخابات هي تقول ان من اسباب ضعف ااا
او فطور هذه يعود اساسا الى غياب التمويل
العمومي الذي حرم العديد من المشاركين من
تنظيم حملات دعائيه ربما تكون كبرى وايضا
يقولون ان هذه انتخابات التي تجري لاول
مره على الافراد وليس على القائمات ان
الافراد غير قادرين على القيام بعمليات
تعبويه وايضا عمليه حشد حتى تكون حتى تكون
هذه الحمله الانتخابيه ربما لكن اكيد
رشيده هو ان هذه الحانه خبيره على الاقل
خلال المده التي حضنها تميزت فعلا بالفتور
وتميزت فعلا بغياب اي عمل دعائي كبير
وربما هذا مؤشر بحسب عديد المراقبين على
عزوف التونسيين على هذه الانتخابات وهذا
العزوف بحسب هؤلاء المراقبين ربما سيتتاكد
خلال يوم الاختراع الذي سيكون يوم السبت
السابع عشر من شهر ديسمبر